[Générique Golden Moustache]
Heeey
Dominique Voyney
Dominique Voyneyyy
Tututututututut
Je l'ai fait trop longtemps
Elisabeth Gigou
Super !
[Rire]
[Rires]
Hier
J'ai téléchargé Camping 2
Mais ...
Tu n'as pas besoin ...
Je ne vois rien
SUPER !!
Il sera jugé demain pour crime contre l'humanité.
Comment bien cuisiner mes girolles maintenant,
Y a t-il des astuces
Laisse moi m'en aller...
ça c'est ma bite!
On met Gangnam Style
On a qu'à mettre Gangnam Style
TA GUEULE ! J'ai pas envie de parler.
TA GUEULE, TA GUEULE, j'ai pas envie de parler.
Je m'en fou ta gueule
Oh non les gars!
C'est coupé.
Noooon !!
Raymond Guenot
Déjà, sois biens heureuse
que je l'accepte à notre table, hein!
Excusez-moi, j'ai vu
l'érection du chien
j'ai un gros problème
pour me concentrer
Oh putain !
Ouuuuuh !
Si je dit que t'es Zelda t'es Zelda, t'as compris ?!
OK...
Noooon !
Daaaa !
ça fait 10 ans qu'on cherche Gégé
Est-ce que je vous ai parlé du mini-frigo de la kichinette?
Nooon !
[Rires]
Action !
On se retient de rire à action, c'est génial non ?
Magnifique 850m²
7 hectars de forêt
Faudra que je t'invite au barbeq', c'est super!
On a vraiment baisés mais comme des clébards !!
Comme des clébards !!
Là où on faisaient des travaux dans l'appart,
à longueur de journée,
on BAISAIT
mais genre mais déguelasse !
Pas de respect, la tête dans la laine de verre !
La gueule sur la placo, BIM !
On a baisé deux... deux fois ce jour là
Dont UNE où on a baisés deux fois
Ahhhhhhh
Ahhh
Ahhhh
Encore une fois
ahhhhhhh
Là !
Ba oui forcément
là !
j'aime bien ici
Là !
Tu préférais quand c'était moi ...
Quand je te sucais la bite
Ba .... ça ...
C'est mal joué ...
Action !
Ohhhh ouais !
Suriiiicaaaaaaaaaaaaaate